Kanye West remains hospitalized one week
after being admitted to the UCLA Medical
Center while wife Kim Kardashian sticks
by his side I think he's exhausted just
really tired husband has been really
it's a grueling tour a source close to
the couple tells et at the initial plan
was for Kanye to leave the hospital on
Monday though the decision was tentative
depending on his doctors decision quote
Kanye's doctors are super reluctant to
diagnose anything mainly because a
mental or cognitive disorder cannot be
diagnosed after one hospital visit but
rather after observing someone's
behavior over the course of a specific
timeframe Kim has been extremely
supportive during his hospital stay
we're told this is quote only making
their marriage stronger a source close
to Kanye previously told ET that the
rapper was battling sleep deprivation
and exhaustion and just needed rest
however another source claimed that
Kanye's suffered a mental breakdown
prior to his hospitalization due to his
schedule and personal stress